sacando la artillería pesada
barack obama apareció nuevamente en
campaña para apoyar a su
exvicepresidente al pronunciarse este
michigan a un estado tradicionalmente de
izquierda pero en el que hillary clinton
perdió en 2016
entiendo que este es un presidente que
quiere ganarse el crédito completo por
la economía que heredó y no tener
ninguna culpa por la pandemia que ignoro
pero el trabajo no funciona de esa
manera
twittear no solucionar las cosas
inventar cosas no mejora la vida de las
personas
debes tener un plan tienes que hacer el
trabajo
mientras tanto donald trump estuvo
concentrado en pensilvania donde realizó
cuatro actos de campaña este sábado
en esta área una de las principales en
materia de producción de gas natural
trump insistió en que su rival abolir a
la industria petrolera de eeuu y
prohibir a el fracking
hace un momento firmé una orden para
proteger el fracking en pensilvania y
bloquear cualquier esfuerzo para reducir
la producción de energía en este estado
lo firme en el hermoso mar in one vieron
eso
trump sigue realizando grandes
encuentros con sus partidarios ignorando
las medidas de distanciamiento social el
mandatario estadounidense ha preferido
evitar enfocarse en el manejo de la
pandemia el país registró más de 100.000
nuevos casos el viernes un récord
mundial las encuestas recientes indican
que su rival joe biden le lleva una
ventaja pero trump prevé otra sorpresiva
victoria